you know in general these two have
played each other a lot we talked about
this earlier I think it's the same kind
of situation as the Christian super noon
set we're familiar with each other
they've played a lot of stuff in
tournament so this should be good 3 out
of 5 this time end up in super noon
being able to go face Kristy again yeah
you know it's funny it's like a college
event saw him take the candy so he's
like what can I do
I mean he looked down at his bag it was
like sick water actually I'm just gonna
say that sunnyville water it's probably
like warm milk right he's just like let
me just get some Fortis favorite thermos
what if he carries around a thermos of
warm milk he probably does I mean that's
right what that was it looks like
they're locked and loaded here yeah
these are the colors I assume they're
just gonna go in hopefully he oh they
both double like no salt the handshake
to each other oh they don't want to get
he's like now I'm not giving you the
handshake Wow well to be fair he said
easier there when he smoked that is true
I forgot almost about that he's
operating the camera easy and then he
was like okay well my good friend
Whitney
let me talk to you on the stage after
yeah and the winner of this is gonna
play Christian grand finals with the
tough task of having to reset the
bracket B Christy twice in two sets of
three out of five and Dragon Ball it is
a tall order for fair I start of the
round we just be super happy that block
was crazy
yeah not standing Allen he was just
willing to take the risk I think that I
like it a lot
Ron's often yeah he just wants to run
that makes it what isn't that was crazy
super noon I mean early you can see the
spots word yeah he's fine alike you know
he's trying to get in his head and be
like look this is how I'm gonna play
this run them over this is the combo
let's go missed incoming yeah miss the
incoming that's unfortunate waiting for
those assists to be back up Gopi beam is
back for a policy man yeah I gotta be
the drop here in the corner he was
scared of the fuzzy this should actually
probably be the kill here all three
characters great choices sparking
they're too into this Pombo knew he
confirmed off of it set in bars yeah
and on the level one thump that level
three Tod off the incoming set of crowds
clapping - they're like wow I mean
sometimes you get small it's like a
50/50 between you know instant overhead
or low and you just die like well it's
be like that orb I don't know that I'm
gonna mess with the combo whatever
whatever apology man just drank out of
that bottle though where they will try
to reflect actually we thought that was
gonna be a lariat or if the demon
connects it or not yeah
[Music]
it goes through the jump heavy
it's the hit yes there's that last
little bar waited to see if the layer it
was gonna kill when it didn't use it on
the vanish I like that a lot
yeah two games apiece you know it's
marking to worry about and I think if
you're super noon this shell feels
pretty solid especially with where you
are but up there for a second with the
2m but drops it double jump bounce super
- down and vanished we see a lot of
reversal vanish defense from super noon
something that he goes to quite a bit
yeah you're you're vulnerable for quite
a while if you whip in if it's just an
easy super - get the punish level 3 with
piccolo to get him out of there and you
want to play the shell probably in this
order if your apology man I think - I
was just talking about that vanish and I
think that's a good read I think the
read was that he was gonna get the
regional combo - who's gonna just stay
on the ground so you try the command row
number one number one
still it's clothes overhead width in the
5a laughter this is completely out of
range he's like he was like well a
little late okay he's waiting for the
super - here on the ground as apology
man with that - H there I was really
really good from super dude he was
waiting and not super dashing early I
think because he knew that that's what
apology meant wanted to miss that GT
cocoa bean not law found by it that's
coming back up though this is super news
chance to go back on all phones ok the
beam doesn't hit o caught doing the five
light dance yeah he try to commit all
the way combo here gonna build up the
three bars Wow
thanks oh yeah wow that was a really
good try
I don't nothing kill those free free the
nerfs that they did to the double supers
that that would have killed like damage
all the super oh so good feels character
oh yeah this character now with double
super home try to get the combo and both
of the hits he's gotten on apology man
in his life barb in that exact situation
where he got under the vanish trying to
get away from the key blasts in the two
age lands super noon with Game one what
what a long game one two their hearts
out there that last bar dog vs. Goku was
white
it was super long I'm just playing that
whole new tree game where apology men
got the hit and there was a couple of
moments where he just had the vanish
where he's like I gotta get out of here
I don't wanna get hit by anything and
then to H on the ground super noon was
ready and willing so brown star we again
early aggression we see from super net a
lot and that's like this right all the
way in and yet the hit but didn't
believe it in like on the dragon rush
both of assists are about to come back
off cleared they're doing a really good
job they're calling out
2-8 she's gonna get it here get the
corner positioning that followed you man
needs got the hell zone grenades yeah I
feel like I'm super - put him in a
really really bad spot fuzzy or not
[Music]
level three yeah I think a good time to
spend to get that extra damage right
here put apology man on spark or not
bragging rush off here
yeah want to actually damage that onto
this it's gonna be the drop level three
bring piccolo back in oh yeah
piccolo probably the best in the game
for running that corner sequence where
snaps juni is really really good option
so not surprising a sparking runs out
here for super noon
gonna be that little bit of keep
haunting a bogeyman here off the GT Goku
assist and look like the tag dogs pretty
slick again no it goes low this time GT
Goku assist available plus frames though
I like to reflect on that managed to get
away
apology man killed the last game that
same exact vanish at this time super
noon does it you know jump in and then
6n behind held on just feels like so
unnecessary it's like you've already got
this crazy oh yeah I'm so sick it's
because he was hitting the assist
character you see Goku's live and then
piccolo fell into it and then it didn't
combo and the vineeth was like oh I can
super - it and he got to AIDS that's
them like Kid Buu shenanigans yeah
tongue out of your opponent yeah it
definitely is
right back at you okay you gotta feel so
smart when you're hot or combo hits like
hey makes you feel like a genius every
time big brain like you did nothing
special for you like man I'm good
I feel it every time I'm and I'm good
Heatblast oh yeah stager presser waiting
for that assistant come back on deck
here and it is back
yeah barkis's Swift's but he had already
got the hit so didn't end up mattering
change in that's gonna win yeah Wow
punished I think it already is this mass
anyway didn't get the knock down so
that's unfortunate for super noon he hit
the assist for a second but didn't
commit to anything more legs oh we got a
boat but yeah falls out still extra
damage that he's gonna add on to go
through here the great spot for super
need to be in because you know even
though he doesn't have sparking to
characters is definitely pretty solid
he's just got to be careful about not
getting both characters hey if I like
sparking go through or something like
that they can just explode goes the
super noon there yeah a little too far
for that extension with the reverse
Kamehameha yeah I like the spark
[Music]
Jane flasch fist beats it and I think if
your super noon you feel okay about this
morning position
we got the hit but believe something in
the air there yeah I mean this is a
pretty rough spot for apology man oh one
of the few times they always say apology
man always upped X and then finally he
was down tacked to eight yeah sparking
but it's running out it's running out
he's got so much meter that's the
important part in the Friant that's high
already hit a pun anyway oh that was
forbidden that was like he broke his
trust he's like I trust you won't hit a
button here come on plus and he says
look it's a fighting game not a blocking
game I'm gonna sit here and die he's
gonna swing him on to him
yeah want a piece man he said you did it
he said you hit that button
he's like a fan bro he's like you're not
scared you just hit that button
he's like why oh yeah easy as button
input of my life or piece obviously
business - here's to three out of five
team go on assist ready on apology man
side there it is
back off go through BL football
elbow has barred offices up to try and
extend yeah please air - in got the age
and now it's in the corner with Bartok a
sister just rain right mystic ball goes
low his defense can really get so far in
and flippin in front of 200 their age
way Oh H legs this hurts there's a lot
of damage to I think may be expecting a
tag he almost got that jump back to H
they're both and the powerful while kept
them together I'm surprised when I've
been involved and holding them stand why
didn't he just drop them and double
super I'm surprised like you don't have
to try to extend with the SS and he's
gonna lose the character for this I
think the idea there was like drop them
and then just like super super super and
take as much damage as you can on the
assist character the skater would've
been freaked probably pretty close to
dying
raises flex there from super noon okay
probably going to be drop here dragon
Raj I like that idea because you know
super noon had to be pretty aware of it
and you managed to beat it which all the
elbow he immediately had a counter for
the Vantage just vanish to vanish keep
the corner position maybe that you
already have super dude down to his last
character those working left in this
game this is definitely the strongest
game so far yeah plating up super here
if a ball I think it's any hit you just
gonna spark up and if it doesn't kill
you it'll be very very very closely
none of this health is recoverable so
yeah solo mix-ups not super scary
they're just the dragon rush around yeah
he found that opening there with it
yeah sparks up oh gee Yas the bit
outside I was a good bait actually from
super noon just random trying to see
what you do on defense and kit boo
apology man going up two versus one
against super noon yeah that was a clean
game honestly the way you played that
was just like super compose didn't get
run over didn't panic too much on
defense
I liked seeing when he adjusted to
playing against super game so far yeah I
think that's the style you have to play
in a matchup like this optech out of
there for apology man I think he's got
to be feeling okay about where he's
sitting on the screen to H Oh way it's
like just point blank he reflected he's
like I want it that's good idea that'll
work
that was scary he had committed to the
reflects the second or third time we
just these long delays from super noon
into like a 2l and it's work or anything
that's really weird I thought he was
gonna do like the theme and the level
one or something a little three but
didn't commit any resources
he's the hell zone no problem apology
[Music]
manner
okay sparking super noon once out of the
situation he wants to make this comeback
here
right there and he got the confidence
time off the kids football off one that
he missed last game should be the kill
the javelin after I think it's a good a
good choice therefore super noon to get
rid of piccolo as fast as possible
definitely been a troublemaker for him
and just like this part ups me get this
hit almost has three bars on deck there
we go this is gonna be enough to kill
team go on yeah
easy kill to bar kill and now I think of
your super noon you're looking at this
like alright well game plans going great
all I have to do is kill Goku and
there's been a lot of people in their
life that have said that sentence like
Android 16 yeah everybody everybody's
like all I gotta do is kill Goku
everybody else is dead no to H
mystic ball
nice double to go ball okay he jumped
out of it I like that to H there
somewhere
turn the Flex he blasts yeah that was
really clean and the extension with the
assist level 1 level 1 volts
yeah I'm very well played I think super
noon in that game just kind of like
steamrolled from the beginning and then
once you just got these hits it's very
hard I feel like to recover right he's
such a scrambling fast player to play
against and if anything goes wrong like
he can very quickly snowball out of
control
absolutely this has been very
entertaining seeing this run back it was
obviously very more one-sided when we
watch them play in the winter yeah and
just for apology man like to be on a
roll this way cornered early I was a lot
of movement from super need to like -
tough jump back like he was really
looking for something from an I'm not
sure to snap early
he just badged it and he'd like
supervisors that I'm out of here he said
you know what suck is it it was not my
time to mix you up so I'm just gonna mix
you up well I was Dazza I don't care
about what's happening
I'm gonna build 3 meters so I can level
3 early
[Music]
yeah more sacra pressures Ichigo quistis
but he just catches the raw age and I
mean with his in sister extent there
should be the kill yeah and not only
that but super noon like got hit snap
and it was like oh oh the here comes the
offense and he just like Bulldogs his
way out of the corner and now isn't a
great spot or the kill yeah that one
incoming mixup not going his way and
look like a Polish man was waiting for
it for a little while but then once you
an airborne it's a little harder to call
Wow wow that was great
I really like my father give him the
head over her head
yeah I'm surprised you got a third
jumping L held a lot of buttons that he
came down with when he was staircase you
know level three
I like that allows pool mixer up think
about being so much more of team go on
now spark up run up he was waiting to
see I think you need upper cover
something this is a bad spot to be I
feel like anybody in the world like when
you see gumball into neutral chump if
you're not go easy
you had the lights just flashed before
your eyes like that's the stance you're
like well guess I'm gonna eat this
damage mark or not or the tag instead no
sparking yeah science which a lot of
life lost three bases spark but he
didn't really have a good answer there
and he was looking to try and grab him
out of the air - thought he was gonna
probably jump over him yeah he's got
bark assist here gumball set up other
side low okay so far good defense here
from ecology man dealing with the
situation just needs a fine is footing
here wow I'm surprised ahead yeah / -
animistic wall is so good having that
mystic ball knock down be mrs. sage 6m
Baraka says bro that was way too an one
mixtape he's just like over and over
that was crazy over six and he's like I
could just break your ankle hold up last
character here for apology man and super
noon they turned it all the way around
from a big that was it
this is sitting pretty here but older to
age from yeah that was a big commitment
on the super - oh no the dropped combo
that's gotta feel bad
that's the guard cancel now
that'll do it level three the modulo
caverna moves super noon back into the
grand finals against Chris G handshake
gave him the left-handed handshake oh
that's rough Wow I feel you there I mean
hit the arcade stick in the right hands
fair enough - working with Zoomer didn't
he was on and I you know he really
looked like even in trouble but he kind
of like you know dug in his feet and he
looked great on that and he's the points
he needs right he's somebody who's
trying to qualify for the World Tour
Finals making it back into Grand Finals
is a big deal right it's a big
difference in points a you want to try
to get there